OK.
We're
now at one hundred and twenty one
attendees, it's wonderful turnout.
Thanks to everyone for coming.
I'll start again.
My name is Stephen Naron.
I'm the director of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies
here at Yale.
Tonight, the Fortunoff Archive is delighted
to present the work of Zisl Slepovitch and
his ensemble featuring Sasha Lurje.
The songs you're about to hear are taken from
the second volume of recorded works based on
the testimonies from the archive.
After the concert, you can learn more about
this ongoing project and listen to both
volumes one and two, and watch
excerpts from the testimonies at the
project's accompanying website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Before we begin, I'd like to thank
Adam Graves from the Institute for Sacred
Music and Rabbi Jason Rubinstein at the
Joseph Slifka Center for Jewish Life
at Yale, for their generous support of this
concert.
I'd like to give you just a few,
a few bits of information about the Fortunoff
Video Archive.
The archive began taping testimonies in New
Haven in 1979.
At the time it was called the Holocaust
Survivors Film Project, or HSFP,
and it was a local grassroots effort by
survivors and supporters in the New Haven
area.
It was the brainchild of Dr. Dori Laub,
himself a survivor from Czernowitz, a
psychiatrist and analyst, and Laura
Vlock, a television journalist at Channel
Eight.
They had the support of the New Haven
survivor community from the very beginning,
particularly in the form of a man named
William Rosenberg, who was a survivor from
Czestochowa, Poland.
And Willy became the president of the HSFP,
organized, helped organize the tapings,
raising funds for the tapings, and holding
meetings in his home.
The collection came to Yale in 1981,
thanks to the work of Professor Geoffrey
Hartman. Geoffrey too was a survivor of
Nazi occupied Europe, having fled Frankfurt
on a Kindertransport for the UK.
And his wife, Renee was one of the first four
survivors taped by the Holocaust
Survivors Film Project in 1979.
Geoffrey helped find a home for the
collection at Manuscripts and Archives, at
Sterling Memorial Library, and under his
watch as faculty advisor, it grew to become
an internationally renowned collection
that over the years has influenced the way
the history of the Holocaust is studied,
written and taught.
Now the collection contains something like
4,400 testimonies, 12,000 hours of recorded
material, in over a dozen languages
recorded over the last 40 years, in over
a dozen countries.
Each testimony in the collection is really a
world unto itself, functioning almost like an
audio visual autobiography because
we use an open-ended methodology that
allows for a great deal of spontaneity and
freedom for the individual to tell their
story the way they desire.
Because of this, it's no wonder that song
and poetry appear in so many testimonies.
Historian Timothy Snyder, the archives
faculty advisor, has said that video
testimony, like works of art, have a special
ability to cross the membrane between death
and life, between past and present.
The singing of these songs can't happen in
a written source the same way.
They can only happen in an audio or
audiovisual source.
The collection, preservation and presentation
of musical performances like these
also places this project in a long line of
venerable ethnomusicological projects
that stretch back to the early 20th century
when individuals like S.
Ansky went on expeditions to record
the musical heritage of a Jewish society that
was disappearing due to modernization,
urbanization and political turmoil.
Ansky called this work salvage ethnography.
This impetus to collect and record,
this goal of salvaging what was left,
continued through the war and into the
postwar period following the Holocaust,
with recordings of songs by David Boder in DP
camps, and later the work of the Fortunoff
Video Archive.
My point is simply, we are not the first to
recognize the significance of musical
expression as a means for understanding
the past, and it most certainly applies to
the understanding of the multilingual,
multicultural world where European Jews lived
and died during the Holocaust.
And with that, I would like to introduce Zisl
Slepovitch, the Fortunoff Video Archive's
Musician-in-residence.
Thank you, Stephen.
Songs From Testimonies in the Fortunoff Video
Archive is a project that explores
and artistically presents music
and poetic pieces performed by survivors in
testimonies given to the Archive.
Some of the songs were from the pre-war
period. Some of them gained new meaning
during the Holocaust, playing
many different roles.
But often songs worked to sustain
people psychologically in unimaginable
conditions when even the
very act of singing a song required
enormous effort.
Some of the songs are not idiomatically
Jewish. They might be songs from
the past that acquired new topical lyrics.
There are songs of struggle and resistance,
many songs that are satirical in nature,
songs documenting people suffering,
songs naming the traitors and
collaborationists.
They are even overtly antisemitic
songs that survivors nevertheless chose
to perform.
This project began several years ago
when Dr. Sarah Garibova, former
Fortunoff Video Archive
Haartman Fellow, began research on the
testimony of Liubov' K., a
survivor of the slave labor camp in
Zvenigorodka, Ukraine.
In her testimony, Liubov' recounts
several songs and poems.
Later, Steven Naron, the Archive's director,
invited me to transcribe and perform
the songs, and the project has grown from
there.
When I started working on this collection in
2018, I only had a sense
of the richness, depth and
breadth of the material I would be examining.
The more I listen to the testimonies,
the more I found myself placing them
in many different contexts: European,
Soviet, Jewish, musicological,
ethnographical, and so on.
When Stephen asked me to record the songs,
it became obvious to me that I had
to contract an ensemble,
a vocalist and instrumentalists, musicians
that would be the right fit for this
very challenging material.
Among those challenges, to name just a
few, are extremely wide range
of musical styles and many
languages in which the vocalists would have
to convince-convincingly perform.
In the two volumes of Songs From Testimonies,
Sasha Lurje sings Yiddish,
Hebrew, Polish, German,
Russian, mixed Yiddish/German
and French.
The two volumes have been the most
stylistically and linguistically diverse
albums that I have ever recorded
or produced.
To ensure that each song is represented
in a historically authentic manner.
A great deal of multidisciplinary research
is required even before the song
is transcribed and arranged.
From the very beginning of this project, I
have been very fortunate to work with Joshua
Camp, who plays the accordion, piano and
the guitar, with bassist Dmitri
Ishenko, violinist Craig Judelman,
and vocalist Sasha Lurje.
Mariana Slepovitch appears on two
songs in Volume Two, on the tsymbaly,
a Belarusian string instrument
similar to the hammered dulcimer.
As time passes, we obviously are moved
farther away from the origins of the
source material, but our hope
is that anyone listening to these songs will
be driven to also learn more
about the survivors who sang them.
The songs represent many things, including
stories of loss and survival,
stories that are still important to hear
today when we are experiencing
a new upheaval of hateful, chauvinistic
ideas and ideologists and
ideologies.
Antisemitism itself, sadly, is hardly a
thing of the past.
Music, in a way different from a verbal
story, has the power to educate,
to challenge people's thinking.
Although I hope I'm not being naive,
I do sincerely hope that this
will be true for these recordings as well.
We will begin our program tonight
with the song, "In Dinaverke."
Lily M. was born in 1924
in Vilna, now Vilnius, Lithuania,
then Poland.
In her testimony, Lily recalls growing
up in an assimilated, affluent
home, as well as the rise
of antisemitism from
1935.
At some point, Lily was transported
to the external slave labor camp
Dünawerke, Dinaverke in
Yiddish, in Kaiserwald, in the outskirts
of Riga, Latvia.
According to Lily's testimony, her friend
Tosia had escaped
with her parents from Lodz to Vilna in
1939, and composed and sang
this song.
Lily characterized Tosia as
a very talented poet.
Tosia did not survive the war.
We believed she may have died
of typhus in Germany around the time
of the liberation in 1945.
In Dinaverke,
By the river, by the woods,
There are Jews
from all over the world.
They all are working hard
out in the cold.
Outside, it’s still dark
The bell is calling to work.
Rows of people are lining up,
The wind is whispering.
The Jews are convicted
But for whose sins?
The day goes by swiftly.
The sun has long set.
They return together
Walking slowly
From the whole day of work
They are exhausted.
But Jews, be brave,
The time shall come,
And we shall work
for ourselve in our own land!
And we will work
For ourselves in our own land!
I would like to turn to the musicians
and ask them to speak about their experiences
working with this material on both albums.
Joshua Camp was the first one of
this band who encountered Songs
with--From Testimonies.
Thank you.
Yeah, I was involved from the very
first duo performances, and
it's been lovely to watch this project grow
and expand to what it is today.
Zisl uses the term "creative reconstruction"
for what we do. And I think that's a great
description of
how we as musicians contribute to a project
like this.
Music performance is an ephemeral act,
but through that act, we can transform
something that is perceived as being
in the past and bring it to the
here and now.
In our current situation, where we as
musicians cannot perform together in front of
an audience, this project has been a much
needed reminder, at least for me,
of the value of music and music performance,
and how it can connect us with our past
and our shared humanity.
"A Dermonung Funem Appellplatz,"
"A Memory of the Roll Call."
Moshe B.
was born in 1926 in Rymanów,
Poland, near the Czechoslovakian border.
After imprisonment in several camps, Moshe
survived the death march to Bergen-Belsen,
where he was then liberated by the British
troops.
In his testimony, Moshe remembers the grim
experience of the daily roll call,
"appellplatz" in German at
one of the concentration camps.
The commandant would order everyone to take
hats off, "Mützen ab,"
and to sing, "Singen!"
Moshe pays tribute to one of
his musically talented fellow prisoners
whose name remains unknown, who
sang this song during the roll call.
My heart is aching,
but what does my cry help,
If no one hears me?
They only chase me,
I feel beaten up.
I have no energy to think.
A human cannot understand,
when tossing a round coin,
On which side it will fall.
One always aspires
To enjoy life,
And have joy in one’s heart.
We will now hear the band perform
the song.
My heart is aching,
How can my cries help,
If no one hears me?
They keep chasing me,
I feel beaten up.
I have no energy left to think.
No one can influence
Tossing a round coin,
On which side it falls.
One always aspires
To enjoy life,
To keep joy in one’s heart.
Man, you are foolish.
Don’t forget,
That all your cries
Are just earth and clay.
Stuffing your wallet,
You think you’re so smart!
Don't forget you come naked,
And naked you return.
You could be rich as Korah.
And bathe in luck,
But here you're just a guest
When you get called back.
Stuffing your wallet
You think you’re so smart!
Don't forget you come naked,
And naked you return.
Man, you are foolish.
Don’t forget,
That all your cries
Are just earth and clay.
Stuffing your wallet
You think you’re so smart.
Don't forget you come naked,
And naked you return.
You could be rich as Korah.
And bathe in luck,
But you're just a visitor here
When you get called back.
Stuffing your wallet,
You think you’re so smart.
Don't forget you come naked,
And naked you return.
Sasha Lurje is the lead vocalist
of this project.
She's truly a creative force, standing
behind many of the ideas you will hear
in this new program.
Sasha, I would like to ask you to share a few
words about your work in this project.
Thank you, Zisl.
Well, it definitely has been--
am I still there?
Just double checking.
OK.
All right.
So, it definitely has
been a privilege, a great privilege
to work with this project
for many reasons.
And first of all, of
course, is the
group of musicians and
artists and scholars that
I got to work with on this.
As a singer, I feel
that learning the songs from real people,
even on recordings
and video, brings a different level of
connection to their stories, and their
personal lives and personal voices.
And by exploring the wide range
of repertoire, styles and languages
that the people that were interviewed
in these testimonies
were fluent in, we get
a distinct picture of what it
meant to be a Jewish person
before before World War II.
Jewish people were integrated into
the society around them and were
polyglot not only in languages,
but also in styles of music, literature,
art and all the various
cultures around them.
Going between Yiddish, German, Polish,
Russian or even other languages
wasn't a special, unique thing.
It was just part of how
the world functioned.
And I get to have this unique
chance to try out these different
voices, cultures and styles
and feel them through my own
voice.
It definitely has been a deeply
interesting and moving challenge
to take on.
And by bringing these songs
to concerts
and recording them, would bring
new life to the stories that people
shared in their testimonies.
We bring these stories
to people and it's so important that
these stories and sounds
get heard.
And as Zisl has already mentioned,
it's sad to know that
a lot of these situations,
a lot of these stories are topical
today.
But learning this,
performing this, listening to this,
helps us remember.
Share our feelings and
experiences and live
through the experiences of
people that were interviewed, and
I hope that it will help
us learn how to be a better human.
Thank you, Sasha.
Kiddush Hashem.
This is another song
remembered by Moshe B.
He sang it as a tribute to Zhelazny,
possibly a former synagogue cantor, a
talented singer in Moshe's own words.
While one, can one can define this piece as
a ballad due to his great dramatic
intensity, it can be also categorized
as an operatic scene.
Such songs would typically
be performed in cantors' concerts on motz'ei
Shabes, after Shabbat.
In this piece, the dramatis personae
include the congregation, der gantser
oylom; the old Cantor,
der alter khazn; the evil
Gentile Sailor, der proster matros;
the old rabbi, der alter rov;
and an old blind Jew, a
yid a zokn a blinder, who ultimately
sacrifices his life to save the
community.
This is one of a series of dramatic and
dramatized Ashkenazic Jewish ballads
that are not coincidentally set on the eve
of Yom Kippur, the Day of Atonement.
This theatrical song performed by
Moshe in a manner almost identical to our
recording, cuts a nearly operatic scene
that belongs to the Eastern European Jewish
musical tradition, while also
resonating with a kind of Brechtian
theater along the lines of what we would
hear from Kurt Weill.
The sun has set,
The day has passed.
The night of Kol Nidre has come
And with it a great deal of awe.
The small beys-medresh is like a cemetery.
The whole congregation has gathered there,
In the old, broken synagogue
Rivers of tears stream from their eyes
When the old cantor recites
Suddenly, at that very moment,
Someone stands up and screams:
One, two, three, four!
The door opens,
A rough sailor walks in.
Ha-ha-ha!
How filthy it is in here!
Who is in charge of this place?
The old rabbi
takes several heavy steps,
And wipes the tears from his eyes.
He asks:
How can I help you, Sir?’
I have hidden a spy in this synagogue!
If I don’t find the spy –
I will burn down this synagogue
Together with all you Jews!
Perhaps there is a mistake, noble sir.
Can you really murder the whole Jewish community?
A spy?
Today, on this holy night?
Quiet!
Friends, it's me
I want to die.
So yells out a Jew, an old, blind one.
I will die for you,
in sanctification of the Holy Name
I’ll go straight to Heaven,
shot dead without mercy.
That's a Jewish hero!
The Jewish people have never seen
such a hero before.
And the congregation at the synagogue
in the quiet morning
cries and weeps,
as the old cantor recites
Kol Nidre!
Joseph W.
was born in Lodz, Poland,
in 1929,
where, when Nazi occupation began,
he and his family were locked
in the ghetto.
One
of Joseph's brightest memories
was Jankele Herszkowicz, who composed
many songs in the ghetto
and was famous as the ghetto
troubadour.
Shtubuneltsto, a Yiddishized version of the
German Stubeältester,
the original meaning of the term, was
a senior soldier
in the barrack room
in the concentration and slave labor
camps.
The word meant Kapo,
a prisoner functionary assigned
by the SS guards to supervise
forced labor or
carry out administrative tasks.
Stubeältester, the room
leader, was the lowest rank.
The next one was Blockältester,
referred to in this song as Blokhovo,
the block or the barracks
senior.
The highest position of a Jew
in a camp would be a
kapo, lagerältester,
the camp senior.
The discovery of the
version of Shtubuneltso
in Joseph's testimony is particularly
important as the
survivors themselves seem
to want to forget this repertoire
and did not sing this song
in the postwar period,
as far as we know.
So let's hear a clip
from Joseph's testimony.
Shtubuneltsto, oh you
have your preferences,
You reprimand one, and you slap the other.
Don’t start yelling,
there’s nothing to eat.
As father said, “Ah! Everyone’s a hustler.”
Shtubuneltso conveys the grim reality
of the unbearable conditions at the camp.
The Yiddish lyrics carry a strong influence
of German as well as camp slang.
It would be hard, if not impossible, to
properly transcribe and understand the song,
if not for the good chance that we received
the assistance of Samuel Norich,
the publisher of the Forward.
Norich was born in 1947
in a DP camp in Germany, where such
slang was still in use.
The freylekhs-like feeling of the song,
as sung by Joseph in his testimony,
becomes a vehicle for the dark humor that
saturates the lyrics.
From early morning on
I am restless.
I must immediately get moving,
And I don’t know where to go.
Over there in the bathroom
They speak different languages.
You run into someone sleeping,
Just like in his own bed.
Head of the barrack - you give out favors:
One gets reprimanded
and another one slapped
Don’t start yelling,
there’s nothing to eat!
As father said,
Everyone’s a hustler!
Lunchtime comes,
I turn black and blue
I run here and there
The Barrack Senior is yelling
He wants to get some rest.
They announce the chow time
Everyone is rushing.
One grain of porridge
And an unpeeled potato
Head of the barrack - you give out favors:
One gets reprimanded
and another one slapped
Don’t start yelling,
there’s nothing to eat!
As father said,
Everyone’s a hustler!
Here, in our block,
The bell has rung already.
To hold your food down,
you shove it with a stick
Oh what a fool I am,
As I have no food.
One starts yelling:
Jew, I'll give it to you!
Head of the barrack
you give out favors:
One gets reprimanded
and another one slapped
Don’t start yelling,
there’s nothing to eat!
As father said,
Everyone’s a hustler!
Head of the barrack
you give out favors:
One gets reprimanded
and another one slapped
Don’t start yelling,
there’s nothing to eat!
As father said,
Everyone’s a hustler!
I have worked with Craig Judelman, a truly
versatile violinist, for many years
in the klezmer band Litvakus, and
I have been always fascinated by
Craig's energy and his sound,
which was exactly what I was looking for,
and also his willingness to
go in depth with any material that we were
working with.
I would like to ask Craig to share his
perspective on working on Songs
From Testimonies.
Thanks, Zisl.
But first of all, I want to thank you and
all of my wonderful colleagues in the band,
as well as Stephen Naron and all the people
who work on the Fortunoff Archive itself,
and especially the people who have the
presence of mind to
record these testimonies
in the first place.
As Zisl has so clearly articulated,
this collection of music
draws on an endless
amount of sources and references,
both Jewish and non.
And that is certainly one of the most
striking things for me when I think about
this collection as a whole.
However surprising
this diversity might seem,
it's actually just what we should expect.
If you study Yiddish
music, you quickly learn
that while there's definitely a way to play
with a Yiddish accent, Yiddish music,
like the language itself, has always been a
conglomeration in a reframing of cultures it
is embedded in.
So often we picture Ashkenazim in isolated
shtetlekh existing in some sort
of primordial, pure state.
But in real life they were always in contact
with their neighbors and many lived in
cities, and in fact,
much of Yiddish culture
was completely imbued with cosmopolitan and
international influences.
Part of what makes understanding and
expressing Yiddish culture so difficult is
the amount of contextual knowledge required
to really understand it.
This is challenging in any project, but I
think for us, as you can see, it has been one
of the greatest challenges: taking a fragment
of a poem or a song sung without
accompaniment during an interview and
searching for a way to transform it into
something someone can listen to in their own
living room and even enjoy it while
still honoring the original meaning and
context of the song.
Whether it's a song about life in the camps,
a popular drinking song of its day,
or even an antisemitic song that somehow
remained in the memory of a survivor, word
for word.
One might think that after the incredible
betrayal these survivors must have felt from
their country, they would have refused to
speak these languages and sing the songs of
their neighbors.
Yet even in these darkest moments when it
must have felt clear that a person's Jewish
identity would always be a barrier to their
national identity in the eyes of their
countrymen, the core of our culture was
and remains something that is in conversation
with the outside.
This is, of course, true not only for Jewish
or Yiddish culture, but for all cultures.
And I hope that our performance of these
songs helps to remind us all of that.
While I've been studying and performing
Yiddish music for a couple of decades now,
I mostly have stayed away from explicitly
Holocaust related material, preferring to
study, perform and celebrate the culture that
lived vigorously before this travesty
and is once again today only growing
stronger.
So often in the America I grew up in,
if we did encounter things that were
identifiably Yiddish, it was in the context
of the Holocaust and associated with feelings
of grief, victimhood and loss.
I choose to engage with this culture, to
reclaim my inheritance, to find life,
to give context to my own experience and
to honor those who came before me.
However, working on this project and
trying to understand the context of the songs
and the people who have encountered them has
been hugely enriching, if a bit
challenging at times.
The scope of the Holocaust makes it almost
impossible to comprehend.
But these songs draw us into the specific
experience of individuals, and even into
specific moments in their lives.
I strongly encourage you all to take some
time to watch the testimonies which are
available on the archive website, so that
when you think about this horrific chapter in
our history, the first image in your mind
perhaps won't be mountains of dead bodies,
but rather the faces of people strong enough
to survive it.
I'm so grateful for the way this project has
been framed, and I hope that as you're
watching these videos, you're able to get a
sense of not of how small and confined were
the experiences of the victims of this
atrocity, but of how big was the world
that they carried inside themselves and how
interconnected it was and remains despite
the continuing efforts to claim culture and
land as the sole property of just a few.
Wow, thank you, Craig.
Yeah, well, the main.
Well, I guess we'll move on.
The next song of Himlen, o
Himlen is a powerful, chilling
song recounted by Moshe
F., born in Uniejów,
Poland in 1913.
When Moshe arrived in Auschwitz,
he met a man by the name of Mayer-Ber
Gutman.
Or Gutman,
probably, who "could write."
He wrote two poems, Azoy
vi ikh bin nokh Oyshvits gekimen, When
I came to Auschwitz, and Himlen, o
Himlen, vi iz mayn glik?
Heavens, oh heavens, where is my luck?
Both were sent to the melodies of popular
songs of the period.
The first one
was originally a rejoicing song
that recounts all the Jewish holidays
and celebrates how
it is good to be a Jew,
vi git es iz zu zayn a
yid.
And the juxtaposition of
this new text and the old melody
creates a sense of tragic irony
that likely would, would have been
clear to the listeners of the time.
The second tune and verse, which
gives the title to this composition, uses
the melody of a popular song,
Vi iz dus gesele, vi iz di shtib.
Gdie eta oolitsa,
gdie etst dom in Russian or
Gdzie jest ta ulica, gszie
jest ten dom in Polish.
Where is that street, where is that house.
It was a very, very popular
song.
When we arrived
in Auschwitz,
They took away the women
and the children.
A great tumult
happened there:
"In half an hour
we will be in heaven."
When we arrived in Auschwitz,
They took away the women and the children.
A great tumult happened there:
In half an hour we will be in heaven.
At night, on our prison beds
We lay our skinny bones
And sleep with hope in our hearts
That soon we will be free.
At night, on our prison beds
We lay our skinny bones
And sleep with hope in our hearts
That soon we will be free.
Heavens, oh heavens,
where is my luck?
The moon and the snow
are hidden from sight.
Where are our children?
In what land?
In Auschwitz, in Treblinka,
torn apart and disgraced.
Where are our children?
In what land?
In Auschwitz, in Treblinka,
torn apart and disgraced.
Heavens, oh heavens,
where is my luck?
I've had an honor of working with
the bassist Dmitry Ishenko
on a wide range of projects
from klezmer band, here the substitute bass
player in Litvakus band, to
improvised music.
Dmitry plays in Zisl Slepovitch
Trio, along with the wonderful guitarist
Nadav Lev, to musical theater,
Fiddler on the Roof in Yiddish being one of
the more recent productions and more,
it is truly my pleasure to ask Dmitry
to share his story of working on songs from
testimonies.
Thank you so much, Zisl.
Well, it has been a real, true honor for me
to be part of this project, and
it really has exposed me to a whole wide
variety of music and a multitude
of languages that comes out of the Holocaust
era and not all of it
being sad, some of it being quite hopeful
and optimistic.
And from a personal perspective,
for me, it's a dedication to the Jewish side
of my family that hails from
Odessa, Ukraine, and
the surrounding areas,
and their struggles during that era,
and to the several relatives that I know
of who have perished during that time
at the hands of the Nazi allies.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dmitry.
This next song, Hej Tam Na Górce,
Hey There on the Hill, was drawn
from the testimony of Yaakov B.
Yaakov was born in Hrubieszów, Poland
in 1926, the youngest of
three children.
He first attended a Jewish school but
then underwent a compulsory transfer to
the public Polish school.
From those years, he remembers walking
around the town with the girls and
learning funny and frivolous songs from them.
Hej Tam Na Górce is a traditional
Polish song with a pronounced
3/4 dance feel.
This inspires us to pair, inspired
us to pair the song with the oberek
dance tune from the microregion
Rezyczyca, a town near Yaakov's
hometown of Hrubieszów.
The song belongs to the group of
light hearted Polish songs
about a soldier flirting with a young
girl.
We suspect that Yaakov
B. might have added his own
name to the song lyrics.
It's impossible to know if the original
version of the song is the
Jewish name, Jakow, or Jankiel,
or the Polish name Jakub.
Over there on the hill,
by the gate,
by the gate, by the gate,
Yakov is standing there
in the morning, oh in the morning
Yakov is standing there in the morning
And the old soldier
is guarding.
is watching and guarding,
And young Yankel is
kissing, oh kissing,
Young Yankel is kissing.
Don’t kiss so many,
just me.
just me, not those, but me.
Because that one will tell
her mother, oh her mother,
Because that one will tell her mother.
Over there on the hill, by the gate,
Yakov is standing there in the morning,
oh in the morning
Yakov is standing there in the morning
Over there on the hill, by the gate,
Yakov is standing there in
the morning, oh in the morning
Yakov is standing there in the morning
And the old soldier is standing guard
And the young Yankel is kissing.
Young Yankel is kissing.
And the old soldier is standing guard
And the young Yankel is kissing.
Young Yankel is kissing.
Don't kiss those ones, just me!
That one will tell her mother.
This next piece, Chlopek-Roztropek,
is composed of two songs from two
different testimonies.
One is the satirical Polish song
Chlopek-Roztropek, Is a Village Hustler,
overheard in the streets
of Warsaw by Zalman
H., then a little boy,
born in 1929.
The song's general concept is poking
fun and at uneducated,
yet street smart peasants.
Zalman did not remember
one of the lines that we're able to
discover in a source that
contained the full text.
As the character is ironically making
fun of his girlfriend, pointing out that
she dresses too fancy, she fires
back, noting that her Wojtek
bought a fur coat from
the Jew in the ghetto.
It was obviously a
cheap coat, and he didn't
see anything particularly immoral
about this purchase.
In my arrangement, I have cut the song's
lyric at that dramatic turn
and transition to the next picture
from exhibition, so to speak, from a
testimony given by Kalman A.
Kalman was born in 1928,
a native of Kaunas, Lithuania.
He resemble, he remembers,
one verse of a song portraying
a strict Polish collaborationist
who is guarding the entrance of the ghetto.
He suddenly becomes happy
when he sees an opportunity
to get a cut of what is
likely food being illegally
smuggled into the ghetto.
The characters of both songs
represent the same
figure: a non-Jew,
former neighbor, who
under new circumstances,
doesn't mind benefiting personally
from the misery of Jews,
the moral opposite of those
who risked their lives by hiding
their Jewish neighbors from the Nazis.
I am a village hustler, I live in a shack,
Life here is not
like it is in silly Warsaw,
We peasants have a
good life in the village,
And the prices in Warsaw
will starve you soon.
You took the furniture
and clothes out of Warsaw,
So, we don’t have anything left to sell.
We are keeping your
pianos in the stables,
Because we don’t have
enough space for that
You called us "foolish rednecks"
And I say, we don’t have fish for brains!
When you come to the
village to shop,
You'll be counting out
how much you owe for days!
We fancy people are not going anywhere,
But we will overcharge you for some lard.
They took everything
from you on those trains,
While we stuffed
our mattresses with cash!
I thought to myself, these are great times
When I saw Kasia wearing silk underwear.
Don’t laugh, my Wojtek,
you’re not any better,
You recently got yourself
a fur coat in the ghetto!
A peasant stands at the ghetto gate,
With a sour face.
He guards the ghetto like a bank,
With a rifle in his hand.
But suddenly he is happy,
And feels like a king.
A brigade is coming,
Fully stocked.
A peasant stands at the ghetto gate,
With a sour face.
He guards the ghetto like a bank,
With a rifle in his hand.
But suddenly he is happy,
And feels like a king.
A brigade is coming,
Fully stocked.
The last song
in our tonight's concert is
Shray, Hertsale, Shray?
Cry, My Heart,
Cry.
The title track on the second volume
of Songs From Testimonies.
In interwar Europe, including
the Soviet Union, Latin
American music was immensely
popular.
It is no surprise that some songs
of survival and resistance during
and after the war adapted
popular Latin American tunes
to new lyrics and became
widespread as new pieces.
The musical origins of the
so-called Treblinka Song
lie in Tango Oracíon,
composed by the prominent Argentinian
composer and tango orchestra
director Eduardo Bianco.
While the Treblinka song is based
on Oracíon, it has its own
distinct feel,
tempo and form.
We find this song in more than one testimony,
both in the Fortunoff--two
testimonies in the Fortunoff Video Archive
and in the United States Holocaust Memorial
Museum collection.
It was sung by Morris K., which
we-- that version we use as the main
reference for this recording, Willy
F., who presents a short fragment
from the song, and Frieda Bursztyn
Radasky, who sang a fuller
but also slightly different version titled
Treblinka Dort, There Lies
Treblinka.
The song conveys the story of frequent
deputations from Warsaw's Umschlagplatz
to Treblinka as seen and felt
by the ghetto prisoners.
Morris K., born in 1917,
heard the song while he was still living with
his family in his hometown, Polaniec,
situated more than two hundred thirty
kilometers, or one hundred and forty miles
south of Warsaw, before
they were ordered to leave in October 1942.
Another survivor, Willy F.,
born in Dzialoszyce in
1928, lived through
the Kraków ghetto, Plaszów,
Skarzysko-Kamienna, and Buchenwald
concentration camps.
He learned the song in Kraków-Plaszów area,
which is even farther away from Warsaw.
A storm raged through the world,
Entire nations remained
without land
Without mercy
the storm destroyed the world
It ripped the sun out of the sky
and turned day to night.
There, not far,
There is a deportation site
Where people are shoved
To the cattle cars.
There one hears a scream,
A child calling for his mother:
‘How come you’re leaving me alone?
Let's go together!’
The police,
They ordered them to move faster.
You will not suffer any hardship
You will get three pieces of bread.
They didn’t know,
They are going to their deaths.
Over there, in Treblinka,
A fitting place for every Jew.
I’m here, you’re there,
You can’t share another word.
Those who come there, stay there,
There, in Treblinka.
The heart pains
When one starts to remember
Father and mother
on the way to Treblinka.
Cry, my heart, cry,
My heart, don’t just say,
That you a Jew.
Sisters, brothers,
dear parents
They are all going together,
They all are going to the poisoning,
Because you are a Jew!
Cry, my heart, cry,
My heart, don't just say
That you are a Jew!
Cry, my heart, cry,
My heart, don’t just say,
That you a Jew.
Sisters, brothers,
dear parents
They are all going together,
They all are going to the poisoning,
Because you are a Jew!
Cry, my heart, cry,
My heart, don't just say
That you are a Jew!
Thank you so much, everyone, for joining us
tonight. I would like to remind you that
you can access Songs From Testimonies, Volume
Two, as well as Volume One
at songsfromtestimonies.org,
which will lead you to the dedicated web page
at the Fortunoff Video Archive.
You can download the album
along with Volume
One at Zisl, Z-I-S-L,
.Bandcamp.com.
Stephen is now copying those links
into the chat so you can click
through. The vinyl LPs
and the CDs are still in production for the
Volume Two and will become available shortly.
However, Volume One LPs
and CDs are available in limited quantities.
Tonight's artists were Sasha
Lurje
and the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble,
Joshua Camp on the accordion
and keyboard, Dmitry Ishenko
on the contrabass,
Craig Judelman on the violin,
and guest artist Mariana Slepovitch
on the tsimbl.
I am Zisl Slepovitch and played the
woodwinds, arranged the songs, translated
the lyrics, wrote liner notes and
conceived this program.
Stephen Naron is the director of
the Fortunoff Video Archive for Holocaust
Testimonies at Yale University.
Dr. Gila Flam wrote an introductory
note for this album, which is also available
on songsfromtestimonies.org website.
Video editing is by Magdalena Hutter,
sound editing by Joshua Camp.
English subtitles are done by Sasha
Lurje.
The vinyl LP mastering,
as well as vinyl and CD manufacturing, and
booklet layout are all masterfully
done thanks to the expertise of Jeff Mueller
of Dexterity Press.
The album art and animation--there is an
upcoming animation which you probably saw
on the social media advertisements--is
done by Yulia Ruditskaya, an wonderful artist
and animation artist living in Brooklyn, but
also my expat from Belarus.
Thank you very much again.
And stay well and see you next time,
hopefully, live.